make your choice saw 10 is the
terrifying prequel we didn't know we
needed it takes place between the first
and second movie so we've got Amanda
returning with an all-new all creepy pig
mask and the somehow touching backstory
of what brought jigsaw to life so on the
off chance that anyone here isn't
familiar with the cultural phenomenon of
barberheimer it's the concept that you
go see two movies back to back that
premiered on the same opening weekend
Barbie and Oppenheimer is a great
example to compare because what saw X is
bringing to the table is well saw Patrol
yep you heard that right saw X and PAW
Patrol are coming to theaters at the
exact same time and yes a lot of people
will be partaking in this hilariously
timed double feature even though the saw
x movie poster is some sort of vicious
trap ready to annihilate a victim's
eyeballs and PAW Patrol is well a kids
movie